I like math.
I like modeling.
I like computers.
But what I wanna do is be able to use it to help people,...
...and so, it's really interesting or kind of exciting...
...that we can use these tools in helping in this humanitarian cause.
Although the food bank of Central and Eastern North Carolina is the largest...
...in the state, they still can't reach everyone.
Enter Dr. Ivy and Dr. Davis.
They're engineers who realized analytics...
...could revolutionize how food banks operate.
They reached out to see how they could help.
The food bank gave us tons of data,...
...and initially, we're like, "Data, data, data,"...
...but data can be a blessing and a curse.
They mined through millions of records...
...and translated the numbers into useful information.
Some of the models that we have developed...
...try to predict the amount of food that might be donated.
The other type of models also try to estimate how many people might be in need of food.
We tried to pull in data about unemployment, poverty,...
...to see if we can get a better estimate of the true need...
...in the counties that they serve.